breaking news from the anime world
tonight the fight for anime of the year
is consuming fans across the globe it's
definitely not a game no anime of the
year is not a game it's not a game it's
been an intense couple of days ever
since voting started you know um every
day I wake up I go to crunch roll I put
in the vote for the anime of the year
I've been doing one finger push-ups to
make sure my finger doesn't break or you
know cramp up at The crucial moment and
get really in there you know been also
using uh know my family's prepaid
minutes to to call everybody I know
which uh my family's not too happy about
but I want my favorite anime to win and
I need to make sure that people know
that the anime Awards is happening and
that they should vote for my favorite
anime oh what I would say to the people
at home is the uh people at home uh go
vote uh fight for what you love and uh
yeah go vote every single day preferably
my anime all
right was that was that was that good